pressure on Brazil's embattled president
jarba Gennaro has intensified after the
Supreme Court's release of an explosive
video the recording of a cabinet meeting
shows the President on a profane rant as
he expresses frustration over his
inability to replace law enforcement
officials it was released as part of a
probe into allegations that Bolton ro
tried to interfere in federal police
investigations into his son's wait for
my family or my friends to get screwed
because I can't change someone from the
security I tried to in Rio de Janeiro
and I couldn't the video from April was
released Friday as part of a criminal
probe into allegations the president
tried to interfere with Brazil's Federal
Police will change them if you can't
change them change his boss can't change
his boss change the Minister the
Minister in question said bolsa Nara was
demanding changes in the top ranks the
federal police and in its Rio division
which is investigating the president's
sons for alleged corruption the
revelations come as Brazil is hit hard
by the corona virus it's poised to
overtake Russia's the second most
affected country in the world while
scenario has repeatedly dismissed the
threat of the virus and he has been at
loggerheads with governors who
implemented lockdowns is our blood it's
our freedom that's true what these guys
did with the virus that from the South
parlor governor that from Rio de Janeiro
amongst others is exactly that Bolton
arose well known for his outspokenness
he's insisting his quotes were
misinterpreted while we're joined now by
DW correspondent Christiana romário
Christiana thanks for joining us
Brazil's president Bernardo is
increasingly in trouble are his days now
numbered actually early
say but it's clear that vaasana' is
under pressure now there are already
many requirements of process of
impeachment being analyzed by the
president of the Congress and could be
that's now after the release of this
video with the increase of the protests
in Brazil the opposition will finally
gain support more support between the
main members of the Congress to finally
put one of these requirements of
impeachment to be voted and then if it
happens everything will depends on the
ability of the boss owners to achieve
the majority to support of other members
of the Congress he is now without a
party he fights with his own party so it
should gain support from the members of
the Congress to avoid this process of
impeachment in case he is going to be
opening do you think it's it's a
coincidence that the video was published
and do you think as well that it could
be perhaps even too much now for his
followers yeah this feature looks like
to confirm exactly what the former
justice minister Sascha Morris said he
left the government last month accusing
President Abbas owner of trying to
interfere in a Federal Police in Brazil
they are that two of his sons are being
investigated for cases of money
laundering and the fake news campaign
and of course mr. Murrow is also very
very popular and I hear he was famous
because of when he was a church he was a
leading corruption campaign a corruption
sorry and not campaign but a judgment
against many corruption of politics case
so he's very popular when he's now
leaving the government he's getting many
of the followers from Boston are with
him well just briefly Christiana you
know did the situation with regards in
of infections of coronavirus in in
Brazil is now higher than the US and
Russia and how will that develop you
know what's gonna happen now with
regards to that how they're gonna deal
with this yeah I think Brazil is going
in a very difficult direction now
because the cases are really increasing
and the problems that the government of
also Nauru he is dealing in a very
confusing way minimizing the virus it's
the beginning and fighting with the
governments that are trying the
governor's that are trying to deal with
that and imposing lock adopts so the
people are just confuse it exhausted in
the tendons I would say is that the
virus would be spreading more and more
well certainly certainly worrying times
Christiana Rama you thank you for that
update thank you